les élections municipales ont montré ce
que nous rendions nous redoutions tous
une poussée de l'entrisme
communautariste dans les listes
municipales dans le val d'oise cousin
ville est revenu un candidat dont le
profil interroge même les services de
renseignement à garges-lès-gonesse la
ville a failli tomber entre les mains du
fondateur du ccf à strasbourg le hidjab
pire cymbales de l'infériorisation de
l'enfermement de la négation du corps de
la femme a fait son entrée au conseil
municipal
dans ces villes comme dans d'autres
l'islam politique trace son chemin
face à un manque cruel de courage pour y
faire obstacle
et préserver notre unité et les valeurs
de la république
le constat de ces élections municipales
et celui du début malheureusement d'un
morcellement inquiétant que personne ne
peut nier
il ya quelques mois le président la
république avait indiqué vouloir
combattre le séparatisme islamiste à ce
jour nous n'avons toujours ni ligne
directrice ni cap clair vous lutter
efficacement contre ces dérives qui mène
à la fracture de notre pays à ce sujet
comme sur tant d'autres il vous
appartient à monsieur ministre de ne pas
être spectateur jeu revenir monsieur le
ministre sur certains de vos propos à ce
sujet et qui m'interroge en effet il y a
quelques années vous aviez parlé de
laïcité punitive
or la laïcité ne doit jamais être agréé
adjectiv et dit faire l'objet d'un
commandement
par ailleurs vous aviez suggéré l'idée
d'un nouveau concordat avec l'islam qui
remettrait gravement en cause les
principes mêmes de la loi de 1905 et qui
dénaturerait la conception largement
partagé par les français de la laïcité
monsieur le ministre s'engager pour la
france c'est accepter de se faire
détester par une minorité gesticulante
au profit d'une majorité qui ne
demandent qu'une chose vivre en paix et
en harmonie dans cette france
intégratrice et tolérante
quel chemin monsieur le ministre allez
vous prendre quelle réponse allez vous
apporter à cet islam politique qui tente
à 1,6
et résidence est à exclure de la
république
une partie de nos concitoyens au profit
du normes religieuses pour vous répondre
la parole est aux